happy holidays everyone there are Jingle
Bells and a child crying in the
background it must be that special time
of year I don't know about you guys but
for me the best part of the holidays is
always the food all your family we'll
say most of them but anyways I was
looking for some new holiday recipe
inspiration so I went online and there's
a bunch of celebrities go to family
holiday traditions so today I'm gonna
put celebrities famous holiday recipes
to the test and decide if their Abbey
family dinner approved
foreign
[Music]
who celebrate Hanukkah but also for
everyone because let's be real lacas hit
different we're gonna do Gwyneth
Paltrow's potato and apple latkes with
smoked salmon
you don't have to be a goany fan to know
that that sounds bomb so step one I took
a baking potatoes as a russet potato and
I put a little bit of water in here
soaked it for about 30 minutes to an
hour just to get some of the excess
starch out so that way they get nice and
super crispy and I'm gonna throw it into
a cheesecloth in a really what is the
best way to do this I do not know it's
definitely not this way it's definitely
not this way oh my god oh I'm gonna lose
them all right
and I'm just going to try to squeeze out
as much liquid as possible this is where
we get our work kit folks oh
you know that it's worth it in the end
because you get crispy latkes and not
just like sad flimsy ones oh I think I
just ripped the cheesecloth that was
aggressive okay let's just let that sit
for a hot minute before I need to rest I
need to rest my muscles I need a rest
day
that is one ball of potatoes I'm going
to do the same thing with this apple
need about half of that amount
thank you
yeah maybe a bit more someone's gonna
lose
gonna get really sore honestly this is a
death trap just waiting to happen the
gift that just keeps on giving okay now
this has a lot more moisture in it so
I'm not sure how I'm gonna pull this off
but we're gonna do our best there's a
lot of juice on the table oh wow I
should have drank that that would be
delicious apple cider okay and suddenly
my like cup of apple
it's just like a little bit of Pulp was
I supposed to do that I'm just going to
use my own culinary intuition on this
one because I have I didn't read the
recipe I'm not gonna lie and I just
usually don't read recipes okay I mean
how could this be bad guys
how could I screw this up that badly
okay what now one egg I'm hoping that
this is one egg it's not gonna be too
much
just trying to use my uh
I only ever drop shells when I'm being
filmed just like too much pressure I
need a third of a cup of matzo meal
so that's about two tablespoons three
four five six
probably about that
um salt and pepper a teaspoon right see
I don't see the point in like really
measuring this stuff too much because
everyone's potato is going to be
slightly different and I didn't measure
my potato in weight so you know I'm just
gonna have to eyeball everything else
and just kind of feel her out probably
good a little more okay all right we
gotta mix
hold it in fold it in
fold it in fold in the
what does that mean mix everything in a
mixing bowl add a bit more mozz meal if
the mixture is if it shouldn't be if
your vegetable if the mixture is very
loose
[Music]
shouldn't be if your vegetables were dry
I mean they were as dry as possible but
then I added a wet a so there's
definitely moisture here
you know what guys the holidays are
stressful for a lot of reasons family
can be stressful gift giving can be
stressful making [ __ ] latkes
shouldn't be the reason why you don't
sleep at night but here we are
um all right uh will this stick together
I think so I think so I think I'll just
add like a hair more just as like some
assurance and we'll call it a day
that's a lot all right let's go fry
these bad boys it's always a good idea
to have one dirty hand and one clean
hand and try not to mix them up
otherwise be washing your hands still
they are raw all right a little olive
oil now size does matter but I actually
prefer them small you got more surface
area for crispiness and got golden brown
oh yeah and then you can eat like more
of them with more smoked salmon
if you they don't need to look perfect
no one's judging they're like shape they
all have their own little personality oh
they'll be would be proud so I am
looking forward to alatka party this
holiday season they're technically
called Hanukkah parties but
I also just have nicknamed them the
fried food party because we have latkes
and we have donuts and like what more
would you want in a meal like cocktails
oh yeah well there's definitely
cocktails yeah that that's
there's no skimping on the booze in my
friend's circles no skimping on the
booze yeah no skimping on the booze you
don't skimp I'm gonna need some kind of
a pleat
hmm
crispy crispy No One's Gonna call me up
for using metal utensil aren't they oh
yeah
I'm doing it so gingerly I don't think
Uncle Roger is gonna like that you're
using metal utensils you're using metal
to scrape your saucepan hi yeah this is
non-stick saucepan I know I know I
already like feel the hate comments but
guys I'm doing it as like gingerly as
possible my plastic one melted so don't
get on me it's the holidays give me a
break so I drain them on some paper
towel and hit them while they're still
hot with a little sea salt okay I wasn't
even trying to alter this in any way to
like turn it into hunger crush and combo
or anything but this is pretty well
balanced like we've got fiber in the
potatoes and the Apple we've got some
fat in the sour cream and we've got
protein and healthy fats in the salmon
it looks beautiful I think everyone at
the party is gonna love it and you can
make your lacas ahead of time and then
just like crisp them up in a 350 degrees
before serving
hmm
the Apple so good okay I feel like we
need a vegetable in here and I was very
excited about Blake Lively's roasted
cauliflower dish I loved Blake Lively
she is gorgeous she's talented she's
married to arguably one of the hottest
guys in Canada we love that so Step One
is we need to pre-soak some golden
raisins interesting all right I think we
add some water
it doesn't really specify but I think
we're just wanting to plump this up and
hydrate them a little bit make them a
little softer great all right starting
with a cauliflower Now Blake says you
can use any color but in the photos she
used green and orange so I was like I'm
not even on a mission to get an orange
cauliflower which I feel also just like
looks more festive just like more fun
got to get all this stuff off though oh
that was a struggle so we got some water
boiling I'm gonna pop this down to
blanch it for a few minutes before we
roast It Off
all right we're just going to toast off
some pine nuts here
all right T minus three seconds before
these turn black so
let's take them out
all right I'm just going to give this a
quick blanch four to five minutes until
it's uh fork tender
half a cup canola oil
uh three tablespoons of rice wine
vinegar
I'm just gonna eyeball this
there you go
teaspoon of salt
it's a lot of salt
a little pinch of black pepper
and some smoked paprika
oh
There Goes My manicure
now we add I guess these soaked raisins
is this what we're doing
yep weird
we're gonna make a dressing out of
raisins
never done this before but Blake you
were giving me some pretty cool
inspiration so I'm gonna go with it
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm intrigued
it's pretty good very interesting and I
think it's gonna be really good on
cauliflower and would also be delicious
on any kind of winter salad so thank you
Blake for that little culinary hack
let's check on our cauliflower I'm gonna
turn her upside down
back in the pool
all right cauliflower ready give it a
good drain to get rid of all the water
onto a cast iron I'm gonna powder dry
just so she gets extra crispy olive oil
some fancy salts
Crunch and it calls for a spice mix
but when I click on the link to get the
spice mix it takes me to like a holiday
guide so I'm just going to improvise
with my own little spice mix here this
is baharat I believe it's got paprika
black pepper coriander cumin cassia
clove cardamom and Nutmeg I feel like
it's gonna go with the vibe so we're
gonna use that
into a 400 degree oven until it's nice
and golden brown all right while it's
warm we're gonna spoon on some of that
vinaigrette
we're gonna do
pomegranate oh yeah
pine nuts
and some Parmesan cheese
it's like snow
with flavor
smells good
me
I am really excited about this so hot
though look at that
um it was delicious I could eat this
whole head all on my own
the raisin vinaigrette oh
Blake you're killing me girl
I'm done I'm done this day this is this
is all I need right here I'm just gonna
keep on eating
[Music]
I don't even care about my tongue worth
it
all right this needs to be cleaned okay
and for dessert we're gonna do it Taylor
Swift's vanilla chai sugar cookies now
basically she adapted this recipe from a
recipe from Joy the Baker and I read her
instructions and they're very different
than the instructions that Joy the baker
specifically gives when she tried to
actually like formalize t-swifts chai
cookies but regardless I'm gonna follow
Taylor's instructions because I mean I
trust this girl she is a mastermind
she's a genius uh I hate baking but I'm
gonna do it for the swifties
okay step one I forgot to take my butter
out in time to get it soft so my little
tip is to fill my bowl with hot water
and just kind of like let it warm up the
metal
dump it out make a mess and then put my
butter in chop it up really fine so that
it kind of like warms up quickly and I
think that'll definitely help oh a
little extra water that's not what you
want
to
cut that out
okay my my tip is maybe not so great
okay this is why I don't bake no one's
watching my channel for baking hacks
because I have no patience for following
recipes I just kind of do things on the
fly all right this is looking softer
okay so half a cup of butter it's always
such a mess to bake
you know what I used to
I used to enjoy baking
when I didn't have kids
and now it just feels like so stressful
because you can't just like
Escape them
and
there's just not enough time to enjoy it
now I'm adding a half a cup I believe I
always have to triple check these things
because I always will [ __ ] something up
uh half a cup of the big bad canola oil
holidays guys enjoy whatever kind of
oils you want
and also control is not unhealthy so
there's your little magic nutrition
tidbit for the day
all right back to it
So the instructions say that these will
not incorporate very well and clearly
that instruction was correct
so I'm going to give it a little bit of
help
because the oils of the butter are
sticking
granulated sugar half a cup which at
least they make it really simple with
the measurements and a half a cup of
powdered sugar
oh
just a minute oh I went over
it's probably okay right
I'll just leave a little in there
if this recipe doesn't work out I'm
gonna be leaving Joy the baker a
scathing review and insist that I did
nothing wrong
now this is where Taylor Swift comes in
she says vanilla
great
um
egg
and this is where Taylor Works her
t-swift magic so I got one chai tea bag
chai
smells good and she just suggests like
putting those spices right in all those
tea leaves I mean we're gonna see
it's a little chunky
it's a little chunky and that's probably
because of mistakes I made earlier on
but The Show Must Go On guys we can't
start this over mama don't have time for
that kids will be home soon and that's
just how we roll so let's just make the
best out of it
high gear
one
and baking powder
teaspoon of quarter teaspoon of salt
great
let's do it very slowly this time
this is great okay smells good now I
have to refrigerate for one hour or
freeze for 15 minutes so I'm definitely
doing with doing the faster version
foreign
because mama don't have time for them
anything else all right what am I gonna
do roll it into something
[Music]
that's good okay I'm just gonna put it
into a bowl and put it in the freezer
all right we're gonna do a quick little
icing Ella
T Swift
powdered sugar
she calls for nutmeg and cinnamon I have
a eggnog blend which is basically nutmeg
and cinnamon just a little bit of that
it smells so good and speaking of eggnog
a little bit of eggnog
husband's clearly gotten into this
not much left but I only need a few
tablespoons all right give it a stir we
can add more
but we can't take away I mean we can add
more
powdered sugar but still
yes
oh it smells so good
foreign
there we go now she's turning into
defrosting look at that
that's a delicious looking royal icing
I just want to eat that
[Music]
all right let's get that cookie dough
wow they actually worked
let's grab a little spoonful of our
frosting
I'm just going to spread it around I
mean I could have piped this but that
okay so for a recipe I thought was going
to be a complete bust these look bomb
but how they taste
that frosting with the eggnog and the
chai spices in the cookie it's really
really good Taylor you're my new baking
hero
my favorite part of the Pate we're gonna
make a cocktail
and I figured the Kardashians know how
to drink so we're gonna do their famous
holiday pomegranate cranberry Rosemary
sparkling cocktail it doesn't seem to
have a name they're just calling it the
Kardashian cocktail so I gave it an
obnoxious name instead let's do it so
the recipe calls for cranberry juice and
pomegranate juice I found a pomegranate
cranberry juice and I'm like that just
saves me a lot of money right I know
so let's start with that it's like a
shampoo conditioner yeah we love a two
in one okay
there you go now a little bit of
Cointreau so you got that like orange
cranberry pomegranate it's a natural
pairing so I see where our girl Chloe's
going
smells like a party boys and girls I am
going to throw a few pomegranates this
is not even the recipe but like I had
them and I think it looks really pretty
it's a bit of a choking hazard after a
few drinks but you know what be
responsible now the best part also the
scariest part the bubbly
oh no it's this
Poppy is she safe
and put her in a cage somewhere else
does everyone have their safety helmets
on okay what kind of cheap ass ball of
sparkling wine is this was given to me I
I guarantee you just been sitting down
there for a really long time and I
guarantee you it doesn't even have any
Fizz we're gonna find out
no she's still good all right
that a girl I mean I kind of
give a very generous swish away pour but
it's the holidays and then we garnish
with a little Rosemary
nice there you go nice
all right cheers happy holidays
mmm I would drink that I could pound
back a few of those puppies
it's a nice brunch cocktail too moms
love brunch day drinking
I feel like that was a successful run I
mean all of those recipes were
surprisingly really delicious I think if
I were to add one of them to my Sharp
family holiday repertoire it would
definitely be Blake Lively's cauliflower
that recipe was delicious it was
beautiful it was something that I think
pretty much everyone will love and it
was also surprisingly nutritious if I
were to skip anything it would probably
be the cookies only because they were a
[ __ ] to make again your girl does not
like to bake but on that note I hope
everyone has a healthy happy and
delicious holiday season if you guys
like this video be sure to give it the
thumbs up I would love to hear about
some of your family holiday recipes give
me some more inspiration subscribe to
the channel and I'll see you next time
on Abby's kitchen happy holidays
foreign
[Music]